hi schön dass du reingeschaltet hast
hier ist deine malwanne ich werde heute
ein Bild malen und hoffentlich habe ich
am Ende des Videos das Bild auch fertig
gemalt denn ich habe einige Video Pläne
und Ideen aber die brauchen ein bisschen
mehr Zeit deswegen dachte ich für diesen
Sonntag mache ich mal etwas
entspannteres und da ich selber gerne
Podcast höre und einfach Leuten gerne
dabei zuhöre wenn sie über sonst was
philosophieren dachte ich mir mache ich
das auch mal und kann ein bisschen und
mal dabei nebenbei und ja macht
irgendwas anderes räumt auf mal selber
ein Bild und macht Euch das hier an ich
freue mich dass ihr
Interesse habt und wir legen jetzt los
ich habe eine Art Skizze so sieht es aus
also ein Mensch mit einem Spiegelei auf
dem Kopf ich fand es eigentlich ganz
lustig und passend weil die Idee für
diese
laberfolge war es über negative Gedanken
zu sprechen und ich bin mir sicher dass
ich ein Problem damit habe negativ zu
denken mir ist das von ein paar Wochen
aufgefallen bzw
ist das Timo aufgefallen der hat das
zu mir gesagt und am Anfang dachte ich
so nee ich bin Vanessa ich bin malwanne
ich denke nicht negativ ich bin doch
eine kleine grinsebacke und das ist doch
was mich ausmacht und irgendwie habe ich
dann ein bisschen länger darüber
nachgedacht und ich finde ja
da ist doch irgendwie was dran also ich
bin nicht mehr ganz dieser grinsekuchen
der ich noch vor paar Monaten war und
ich frage mich die ganze Zeit woher
kommt das wie wird man so negativ zack
hat mir Pinsel zugeschickt und ich packe
die ganz gerne ich weiß nicht ob sie
sich jetzt gerade für diese Farbe eignen
aber wir probieren das einfach mal aus
ich sollte aber ein ganz bisschen mit
Bleistift vor skizzieren ich bin nämlich
immer so ein bisschen Hals über Kopf in
so Sachen drin und dann gefällt mir am
Ende doch nicht Bleistift
seid ihr bereit wenn ich ein negative
Gedanken denke boah das sind ganz schön
viele Gedanken die heute ausgesprochen
Gedanken das Denken lose denken der
Gedanken kennt ihr das noch von Hermine
wenn das Denken muss denken der Gedanken
und Denken darin denke ich so ein
bisschen
negative Gedanken aber nicht nur
negative Gedanken sondern auch diese
ganze negative Einstellung
also ich habe das Gefühl das hat so
ungefähr mit Corona angefangen also
da wenn ich so jetzt so an die
Vergangenheit denke dann denke ich da
war irgendwie so ein Knackpunkt und gar
nicht mal weil ich negativer geworden
bin aber bei mir einfach zu der Zeit
aufgefallen ist dass die ganze Welt so
negativ geworden ist
2015 als die flüchtlingskrise begonnen
hat und ich gemerkt habe wie viele Leute
dagegen sind das flüssig Flüchtlinge ins
Land kommen weil
Angie hat ja die Tore aufgemacht und die
Flüchtlinge willkommen geheißen was ich
damals eine mega Sache fand ich will gar
nicht darüber nachdenken was jetzt in
den Kommentaren stehen wird naja auf
jeden Fall ja habe ich dann immer
gedacht
also so das ist mir schon aufgefallen
dass es
mehr Menschen in meinem Umfeld bzw
einfach im nicht im Extrembereich gibt
die gegen Flüchtlinge waren oder dass
sie ins Land kommen oder halt ja
irgendwie so eine total negative
Einstellung zu einem hatten und dann
durch Corona ist es
ja es ist einfach
explodiert also durch die
Querdenker dann durch die ganzen Demos
und diese Spaltung zwischen den Menschen
und
hatte einfach oder ich habe einfach das
Gefühl
es hat sich was verändert so und die
Menschen sind negativer und es ist
einfach mehr negatives
zwischenmenschlich ich finde auch das
liegt viel an Social Media
ich habe das Gefühl jetzt wo nicht nur
junge Leute auf MySpace abhängen oder
ihre Schüler VZ Seide machen also jetzt
tummeln sich gefühlt alle auf Social
Media und das bedeutet natürlich auch
man hat mehr von diesen Leuten die
ihre extremen Meinungen eigentlich sonst
nicht teilen könnten jetzt haben sie
halten Ort wo sie es teilen können so
das ist immer meine Vermutung warum man
das Gefühl hat dass oder warum das
Gefühl mehr wird von
Leuten die sage ich mal nicht so
tolerant wirken wie andere so ich habe
das Gefühl es sind einfach mehr aber ich
glaube es sind einfach nicht mehr an
die wirklich
neu dazukommen sondern einfach nur die
sitzen Möglichkeit haben sich
auszudrücken
ja aber
auch während Corona blieb ich eigentlich
relativ positiv also ich hatte jetzt
keine also ich hatte immer Hoffnung dass
das alles wieder bald vorbei ist und
dass die Menschen sich dann alle
hoffentlich wieder bald lieb haben und
so aber in letzter Zeit und da hat Timo
auch recht dann gehabt als er mit mir
darüber gesprochen hat oder mich darauf
aufmerksam gemacht hat ich bin super
negativ und das sind so Kleinigkeiten
das fängt dann schon an
und Pinsel
fängt dann schon an mit so setzen die
ich von mir gebe wenn mich jemand fragt
hey wie sieht's denn aus mit eurer
Wohnung
wie sieht's aus mit eurer Wohnung wie
läuft's und ganz ehrlich es läuft an
sich ganz gut also wir haben zwar vier
Monate Rückstand also vier Monate
Verzögerung im Bauch das bedeutet wir
müssen halt auch kommen tatsächlich auch
ein paar Kosten dadurch dann auf uns zu
Bereitstellungszinsen und so aber ich
möchte jetzt damit nicht helfen das ist
alles
Bankkredite also ich hasse dieses Thema
naja ähm aber wir können das trotzdem
stemmen es ist jetzt nicht so dass das
bei uns dadurch irgendwie die Existenz
bedroht ist oder dass es
ja das ist
eine Auswirkung hat auf uns weißt du
natürlich ist es blöd Geld mehr Geld zu
verlieren als man gedacht hätte aber wir
hatten für diesen Bau und für dieses
hatten wir Geld eingeplant und
ja das ist halt immer noch im Rahmen des
eingeplanten Gelds
aber wenn mich Leute jetzt fragen und
sagen ja wie sieht's denn aus wann ist
denn Einzug und so dann habe ich immer
irgendwas negatives zu sagen wir zum
Beispiel wir müssen badezimmer fliesen
raussuchen und da wo die Baufirma
badefliesen oder oder Fliesen
bestellt und wer sich dann auch quasi um
den um das Verlegen der Fliesen kümmert
die haben halt keine so große schöne
Auswahl nicht so wie wir uns das
wünschten und ja dann haben wir ein
bisschen versucht rauszufinden ob wir
auch woanders Fliesen her kriegen können
und ähm weil wir hatten schon so für
unsere zwei Bäder wir hatten schon einen
Plan wie wir es einrichten wollten und
beide weder sollten ein bisschen anders
sein also tatsächlich
wird das eine warte in diesem grün so
ein bisschen also in so einem dunklen
waldgrün
eingerichtet und das andere sollte in so
einem lachstum sonst was naja und diese
Fliesen hatten sie aber nur für das
grüne Bad und dann hatten sie aber keine
schöne Alternative für das andere und
dann hatten wir uns da jetzt mal nichts
rausgesucht und haben jetzt erstmal mit
der Baufirma gesprochen was wir denn
jetzt machen können und
so und wir können da welche rausfinden
das dauert jetzt halt alles ein bisschen
länger und ist ein bisschen nerviger als
gedacht aber an sich ist alles noch in
Ordnung und wenn mich heute jetzt jemand
fragt ja wie läuft's mit der Wohnung
dann habe ich immer in den letzten
Wochen gesagt ja ähm hör mir auf äh
Fliesen obwohl das gar nicht so schlimm
ist also klar ist es nervig und so aber
es läuft immer noch alles relativ nach
Plan wir ziehen immer noch Ende des
Jahres ein ähm wir ja freuen uns da
total drauf das ist ein riesen Traum ich
meine gerade zur heutigen Zeit früher
bei unseren Eltern da hat sich ja
gefühlt jeder ein Eigenheim leisten
können so das war natürlich auch nicht
so es hat sich auch nicht jeder gekauft
aber es konnten sich viel mehr leisten
so und das ist ja auch auf tiktok und
über alles das ist ja kein Geheimnis
dass unsere Eltern einfach
also ich meine das ist auf tiktok halt
auch so sich drüber lustig gemacht wird
bzw kritisiert wird
ja und das ist kein Geheimnis und
deswegen also denke ich mir what the
[__] was ist mein Problem ich ziehe
immer noch am Ende des Jahres da ein in
unsere erste Eigentumswohnung die wir
uns zusammengeholt haben die wir auch
mit einem Kredit natürlich abbezahlen
also haben sie mir nicht auf einen
Schlag da gekauft aber
wir haben halt die Möglichkeit so und
uns wird die Möglichkeit gegeben und wir
haben sie gegriffen und und freuen uns
da jetzt auf dieses Eigenheim natürlich
weiß ich überhaupt nicht ob das eine
gute Entscheidung ist weil wenn man
Investment Leute fragt dann kann das
natürlich immer also
haben viele Leute verschiedene Meinungen
zu Immobilien und ob das wirklich eine
gute Wertanlage ist und sowas
negative Gedanken zu ich weiß manchmal
nicht ob es die richtige Entscheidung
ist aber ich freue mich so warum kann
ich dann nicht wenn Leute mich fragen
hey wie sieht's mit der Wohnung aus
warum kann ich dann nicht sagen ja super
also was heißt super aber ja wir freuen
uns bis jetzt läuft alles nach Plan wir
ziehen Ende des Jahres ein es wird
fleißig gebaut und wir freuen uns so
nein ich muss dann sagen ah ja hör mir
auf die Fliesen und eo ich wollte nie so
jemand sein der immer nur am meckern ist
ich weiß nämlich es gibt Situationen in
denen du dich beschweren darfst
zum Beispiel jetzt mit der Inflation
wenn dann Familien die wirklich oder
auch Einzelpersonen die vorher schon
gestrackelt haben mit Lebensmitteln sich
leisten können und so ich bin ja genauso
aufgewachsen meine Eltern haben oder
meine Mutter hat Lebensmittel eingekauft
in einem Laden wo es abgelaufene
Lebensmittel gab und Sachen vom Vortag
oder Fehlproduktion so ich weiß wie es
ist dass man nicht einfach ein
Supermarkt gehen kann und sagen kann wir
packen uns rein was uns schmeckt
so und wenn jetzt Leute in dieser
Situation sind und die Inflation hättet
und sie einfach sich noch mehr denken
wie sollen wir uns das leisten das kann
ich verstehen aber ich habe das Gefühl
es sind viele so wie ich geworden und
vielleicht doch alles ein bisschen
parallel mit Corona
die einfach
gerne mehr sich beschweren es gibt
natürlich Gründe sich zur Zeit zu
beschweren aber
irgendwie ist der Grund Grund
ist irgendwie anders geworden aber darum
soll es gar nicht gehen das andere
negativ sind sondern dass ich negativ
bin ja und das ist so eine Situation die
ist mir richtig
also das ist etwas da ist es mir richtig
bewusst geworden
mit der Wohnung aber jetzt zum Beispiel
auch
die ganze Grundeinstellung ist einfach
anders wie ich wie ah ja wie ich auch
über Menschen teilweise Rede das ist
jetzt wenn ich so darüber nachdenke das
ist so asozial wenn ich mit Leuten
zusammenarbeite ach so also ich habe ich
rede nicht zu jemandem direkt negativ
ich bin zu niemanden gemein ich verletze
niemanden so aber im Hintergrund wenn
wir dann irgendwie arbeiten und dann
klappt irgendwas nicht oder jemand
verhält sich so wie ich das nicht mag
oder nervt einfach dann rede ich mit
meiner Managerin also und sie ist
überhaupt nicht negativ die sagt gar
nichts Böses aber ich sag dann so Sätze
wo ich dann jetzt auch so im Nachhinein
denke wann bin ich so geworden dass ich
so so
abschätze ich dann über Leute Rede und
dann sagt
ich will gar nichts wiederholen aber ne
dann so so boah die hat auch ihren Beruf
verfehlt so was für eine was für eine
Zeitverschwendung und und warum müssen
wir überhaupt mit der sprechen oder so
und das sind so Sätze
ja die sind einfach gemein auch wenn die
Person ist nicht hört sich so über
jemanden zu stellen und so abschätzig zu
reden und das ich
macht das echt mehr als früher und und
ich habe mich dann gefragt woher das
kommt wann hat das angefangen aber ja
Corona ist das die Zeit ist wirklich
wegen so viel negativen in der Welt aber
ich glaube am Ende des Tages bin ich
einfach selber schuld ich glaube ich
habe mich aus welchen Gründen auch immer
nicht ich meine das können ja auch
private traurige Gründe sein man hat ja
auch selber so viel Trauma und was weiß
ich nicht alles aus irgendeinem Grund
bin ich auf jeden Fall so geworden und
ich will das nicht mehr also ich denke
mal da ist es halt auch so Einsicht ist
der Staat so Besserung
und ja das sehe ich wirklich so also
jetzt wo ich es anerkenne und es mir
selber bewusst geworden ist und ich und
ich selber sagen kann ja
ich habe dann ein Problem und es ist
ja es ist schlimmer
also ja ich habe da ein problem ich habe
da ich habe da mich in der Richtung
entwickelt die ich nicht mag ich möchte
besser werden und anders werden ich
möchte definitiv daran arbeiten ganz
dringend möchte ich daran arbeiten wie
ich über also wie ich einfach über
Menschen rede ich glaube man gewöhnt
sich da schnell vielleicht etwas an und
da kommen wir zu dem Punkt wie entsteht
das dass man so grundlegend negativ wird
oder warum
weil man kann ja es ist was anderes wenn
man einen Tag lang mal einfach schlechte
Laune hat und dann sagt man vielleicht
auch Sachen zu im Streit oder so die man
gar nicht so meint und man zurück nimmt
und
darum rede ich nicht ich rede um dieses
grundsätzlich sein Charakter verändert
oder so in seinen Charakter zu verändern
und einfach anders zu sein als man noch
vor paar Wochen war ein paar Monaten ich
glaube sonst verhalten
ist
wie ein Teufelskreis
also du bist was du isst
und du bist was du sagst und denkst und
ich glaube man kann sich da einfach drin
verlieren wenn man halt also wenn es
einem nicht auffällt sagen wir mal ich
fange irgendwann ich habe einfach
irgendwann damit angefangen
negativer zu denken als sonst und habe
da mal dann so
sagen wir mal wegen dich Corona alles
ist irgendwie scheiße man darf nicht
raus so dann fange ich an negativ zu
denken
und das füttert ja noch mehr Negativität
ich werde ja nicht aus vielen negativen
Gedanken rauskommen und sagen
ach ja was für ein schöner Tag die Sonne
scheint ich lieb das Leben nee man geht
ja dann eher in die andere Richtung und
füttert noch mehr diese negativ Gedanken
Spiralen und alles wirkt plötzlich alles
alles ist wie so durch so ein wieso
durch das Gegenteil einer rosaroten
Brille
ich habe es gestern tatsächlich dann
schon mal ausprobiert
positiv zu denken in einer Situation wo
ich
sonst ja was heißt sonst ich war da auch
super negativ also ich bin ein Mensch
ich hasse es zu warten wenn ich irgendwo
hinfahre dann muss ich das wirklich
akribisch gut planen dass ich so ankomme
dass ich bloß nicht zu früh da bin also
zu spät es geht auch nicht und so zwei
Minuten zu früh das ist für mich okay
oder 3 Minuten wenn ich aber irgendwo
hinfahren sollte wo ich
wo ich so 15 Minuten warten müsste
niemals ich fahre also dann warte ich
lieber zu Hause und fahre so los
dass ich
ja tatsächlich
genau pünktlich da bin bloß nicht so
voll bloß nicht warten und dann war ich
da gestern mit Timo am Alexanderplatz
und wir haben halt auch Freunde gewartet
weil wir alle zusammen was essen
gegangen sind
ja und die hatten ihre Bahn verpasst du
mussten die nächste nehmen das heißt wir
mussten so ungefähr acht Minuten auf die
warten das muss ich dazu den zu tun oder
nicht
ich habe aber noch ein paar Minuten
gesagt so ach komm dann lass uns doch
einfach schon vor ins Restaurant gehen
dann kommen die halt nach oder meinten
diese nee nee wir sind wirklich gleich
da wartet kurz
und
das ist mir sehr das ist mir echt schwer
gefallen da positiv zu bleiben und ich
habe die ganze Zeit versucht alle
möglichen positiven Gedanken
daraus zu holen und mein positivster
Gedanke den ich daraus entwickeln konnte
war
zu denken na ja dann haben wir ja fürs
nächste mal gelernt dass wir uns nicht
so treffen
[Gelächter]
und da ist es mir super schwer gefallen
muss da also ich glaube auch nicht dass
man so schnell ne natürlich
sich umstellen kann und ein kleiner
positiver Clubs ist wenn man warten muss
ey warten
warten ist wirklich mein entgegen
weiß aber gar nicht ich bin doch ich bin
pünktlicher Mensch ich hatte gerade
Angst dass ich dass ich das sage aber im
Endeffekt gar nicht pünktlicher Mensch
bin und dann sind Doppelmoral aber nee
ich bin schon pünktlich
ich hoffe das hört jetzt hier keiner mit
denen ich mich in der Zeit getroffen
habe und ich pünktlich war
cute we love it
es sieht ein bisschen aus das Bild was
ich male das sieht bis jetzt aus wie so
ein
Muffin auf einem
Teller aber ja we love it wie machen wir
das denn wie drehen wir das denn jetzt
um in etwas Positives
ich habe das Gefühl ich muss
an meinem Unterbewusstsein arbeiten also
ich bin ich bin ein großer Freund von
Hörbüchern ne ihr wisst es also wer mich
schon länger verfolgt weiß
antivirt Soul z.B deine Seele will frei
sein heißt es auf deutsch
tolles tolles Buch wenn ihr euch stark
fühlt in negativ
Gedanken aber das ist auf jeden Fall
kein Heilmittel gegen Depression das
will ich nicht sagen aber wenn ihr in
einer schwierigen Lebensphase seid hört
sich mal dieses Hörbuch an mir hat das
echt sehr geholfen also bis heute auch
nachhaltig hat hilft mir das Prinzip
dieses Buch so gut ich bin ein Fan von
Hörbüchern und
ja habt ihr jetzt gerade so zwei
angefangen und das eine Hörbuch fand ich
schon richtig krass also da hat sie
gesagt die Person
das der Mensch
60.000 Gedanken am Tag hat ich weiß
nicht ich glaube die sind unbewusst und
bewusst halt gemischt
ja aber 60.000 Gedanken habe ich gedacht
gut
und da ging es dann halt darum dass wie
viel sollten wir auf einzelne Gedanken
wert legen
ne Lösung ist einfach nicht so viel wert
man hat ja echt manchmal richtig
quälende Gedanken auch also gerade so
kurz vom Einschlafen habe ich immer so
die schlimmsten Gedanken also so die die
am meisten weh tun und irgendwie so
verzweifeln sind und
ja sobald ich so zur Ruhe komme manchmal
ist schlimmer und manchmal ist es
weniger schlimm aber
vorm Schlafengehen es ist halt auf jeden
Fall immer so die stille ich bin kein
professioneller Podcast der über
psychologische Dinge spricht okay
aber der Mensch kann sich halt
umprogrammieren also so wie man sich ins
Negative rein programmiert hat was ich
jetzt gemacht habe geht das halt auch in
die andere Richtung
und ich könnte mich jetzt wieder positiv
und programmieren und ich will halt
nicht dieses
ich will nicht so dieser toxisch
positive Mensch sein der in allem was
Gutes sieht
aber ich würde schon gerne auf jeden
Fall
hat ein bisschen wieder leichter einfach
leichter wieder durchs Leben gehen wenn
ich an die Welt denke ich denke nur an
das Negative ich meine klar
das kommt auch gerade so von der Zeit in
der wir leben ne und dem Klimawandel und
so man kann sich ja auch nicht belügen
und so tun als ob es nichts gibt auf der
Welt was scheiße ist und
toxisch positiv sein aber der Mensch
muss ja noch ein bisschen
hoffnungsvoll bleiben und das Leben noch
als lebenswert sehen und die Erde oder
oder die Gemeinschaft irgendwie noch
fühlen und
das will ich halt
so wie hier soll es überall aussehen
und ein anderes Hörbuch das habe ich
jetzt auch angefangen deswegen habe ich
kann euch die noch nicht empfehlen also
ich habe die noch nicht durch deswegen
will ich die noch nicht empfehlen
da fange ich da habe ich auch gerade mit
angefangen und ach da geht's da ist mir
immer ein bisschen zu viel Jesus und
Gott in in jedem zweiten Satz ich mag
die Gedanken weil da geht es viel ums
Unterbewusstsein dass man das
Unterbewusstsein natürlich auch
überhaupt nicht unterschätzen darf weil
da findet eigentlich alles so statt das
so wie man es füttert das
Unterbewusstsein und wie man es
behandelt und so das daraus sind sich ja
auch Sachen resultieren können positiv
oder negativ
was ich auf jeden Fall sagen möchte ist
dass alles Wissen ist Zustand es ist
nichts Finales ist wenn man negativ
drauf ist und das bemerkt dass man sich
irgendwie verändert hat das heißt nicht
dass man sich für immer verloren hat man
ist einfach gerade
eine Phase die man vielleicht auch gar
nicht selber so mag und dann muss man
sich arbeiten
ich habe vielleicht einfach auch mein
inneres Kind verloren und meine
Sorglosigkeit muss jetzt einfach wieder
ein bisschen mehr basteln und meinen
dass er sich was machen
es könnte natürlich auch sein dass ich
einfach eine midnight crisis erlebe wann
ich dieses Jahr 30 werde und die ganze
Zeit nur einrede dass ich kein Problem
damit habe aber jetzt mal ernsthaft ne
ich habe also
so viel zum Thema negative Gedanken ich
habe aber was das Alter alt werden
angeht also gerade was 30 werden angeht
habe ich irgendwie keinen negative dann
ich denke da schon irgendwie öfter dran
als jetzt an meinen 29 Geburtstag oder
mein 28 oder was ich was also das war ja
Chili Controller dagegen
aber also ja
irgendwie ich freue mich da auch drauf
ich freue mich ja drauf irgendwie ein
Erwachsener also immer Erwachsener zu
werden
fühle mich auf jeden Fall noch absolut
nie erwachsen
ich weiß nicht ob es an meinem Job liegt
oder an meiner allgemeinen
Lebenseinstellung aber ich bin auf jeden
Fall schon erwachsen
ich finde es immer so witzig meine
ganzen Mädels auf tiktok darüber
erzählen was ihr Freund alles nicht in
der Beziehung macht und und dass sie
alles liegen lassen und so und sie sich
da immer alles kümmern müssen also bei
Tim und mir ist es nicht andersrum dass
ich ihn jetzt quäle und er da irgendwie
mir hinterherräumen muss aber es ist auf
jeden Fall schon so dass ich
ich kriege schon sehr viel Unterstützung
von ihm und also es ist bei uns für die
fifty ich glaube ich müsste mit Öl malen
gerade für solche Geschichten da oben
ist wahrscheinlich Öl einfach besser
aber Ölfarbe kann ich einfach nicht
leiden also ich habe aber ich kann sie
nicht leiden
im Bezug auf sauber machen ich finde
Ölfarbe wenn man mit Ölfarbe gemalt hat
hinterlässt man so eine Sauerei dann
muss man die Sachen sauber machen dann
ist alles voll mit dieser Ölfarbe ich
habe schon so viele Pinsel daran
verloren weil ich irgendwie die Bilder
dann doch nicht richtig sauber gekriegt
habe und dann wird das hart und dann
kriegt man es nie wieder weg
finde ich merkt man seinen aktuellen
Gemütszustand am besten wie wie nennt
man zur Zeit man sich ist
wenn ich male und etwas nicht wirklich
gut mal oder ist
nicht so aussieht wie ich es mir
vorgestellt hatte an meiner Reaktion
darüber zu mir selbst weiß ich wie ich
mich zur Zeit mag oder nicht mag und das
ist so gemein jetzt überlegt mal
jemanden
Tochter oder eine Freundin oder so
Freund und dann guckt ihr euch das an
und seid einfach gemeinsam über die
Bilder
ich meine man findet für Menschen die
man lieb hat findet man immer irgendwas
was man also selbst wenn man es nicht
gefällt dann würde mir immer irgendwas
einfallen dass ich dazu sagen kann sage
ich halt ja
interessante Farbe Auswahl oder keine
Ahnung aber zu sich selber ist man so
gemein
oh das ist aber auch etwas was ich sagen
würde also selbst meine negativen
Gedanken mir gegenüber sind schlimmer
geworden also jetzt nicht nur dass ich
über andere Leute schlimmer denke oder
rede ich rede auch über mich selbst
glaube ich sehr viel schlechter als noch
vor einer Zeit und ich traue mir auch
selber nichts mehr zu also immer wenn
ich auch Zuschauer auf der Straße treffe
dann und die total die netten Sachen
sagen und oh ich liebe deine Videos und
so irgendwie gucke ich die dann manchmal
an und denkt mir so nee du das sagst du
gerade nur so das stimmt gar nicht du
sagst einfach nur was Nettes sagen und
deswegen sagst das ist meine Videos
gerne guckst aber an sich wirklich das
gar nicht das denke ich
das ist schon nicht in Ordnung
ist selbst gegenüber oder Timo war
gerade hier drin ich schneide das aber
nicht rein und ich muss euch jetzt sagen
ich bin komplett raus der hat mir
irgendwie Stoß erzählt
und hat vergessen dass ich gerade
aufnehme
ja und ich bin komplett raus also mache
ich jetzt erstmal so ein bisschen weiter
und werde schon irgendwo einen Anschluss
wieder finden ich mache kurz eine Pause
lass mal ein bisschen die Farbe trocknen
und dann geht's gleich weiter ich habe
eine Spraydose gefunden und ich würde
gerne
zu meinem Menschen jetzt ein bisschen
Nebel malen
ich habe einfach Bock mit der Spraydose
zu sprühen
so ich habe gedacht vielleicht so Wolken
ja ich bereue das jetzt schon aber es
ist okay
hier ist so eine Wolke da ist eine Wolke
hier
mein Gott stehen das Zimmer
aber das ist natürlich nicht alles die
Wolken von meinem Wissen natürlich noch
klar das wichtigste ist mir jetzt aber
auch noch ein bisschen was
ich mir denke was könnt ihr vielleicht
daraus mitnehmen ich möchte Content
machen der euch vielleicht auch ein
bisschen hilft und vielleicht denkt ihr
auch einfach mal darüber nach was ihr
für
eine allgemeine Lebenseinstellung ihr
habt gerade habt und ja man darf sich
darauf ein bisschen auch ausruhen dass
vieles gerade blöd ist und ich habe das
Gefühl gerade unsere Generation oder
auch wenn sie und so also die Generation
vor uns hatten was die Zukunft angeht er
so ein
industriellen
Wachstums also ja das war so
industrieller Wachstum und und
sich selber denken das war das was man
angestrebt hat das war das wichtigste
aber da sind wir natürlich nicht mehr
wir sind jetzt
in der Phase wo wir unsicherer der
Zukunft gegenüber sind und deswegen
möchte ich sagen dass es halt
okay ist das dass man sich nicht immer
super fühlen kann und dass viele
Probleme auf also auch ja gerade was
krieg
es gibt genug es gibt genug Scheiße zu
zeigen über die man sich aufregen und
und traurig sein kann aber man darf sich
natürlich nicht dabei verlieren und man
darf nicht dabei noch die Hoffnung ans
Leben und dann Glauben an die Menschheit
irgendwie so verlieren auch wenn das
sehr oft so scheint als ob das alles
verloren ist ja und vielleicht könnt ihr
da so ein bisschen was mitnehmen für
euch und vielleicht überdenkt ihr auch
mal zu Zeit wie ihr so das Leben
betrachtet und ob ihr vielleicht eurem
Unterbewusstsein auch viel zu viel
negative Gedanken
schickt und euch gerade auch vielleicht
so programmiert habt oder auf dem Weg
dahin seid euch so zu programmieren das
alles schlechter zu sehen und negativen
Gedanken einfach versuchen zu sein ich
glaube halt einfach dass man
seine eigene Realität auch erschafft und
auch in der Lage ist seine eigene
Realität wieder ein bisschen
umzuprogrammieren ein bisschen gute
Gedanken sich wieder machen kann
ich sag nicht dass davon Probleme
weggehen ich bin mal ganz vorsichtig mit
dem was ich sage weil ich natürlich
niemanden auf dem Schlips treten möchte
und anders als andere glaube ich jetzt
auch nicht dass
keine Ahnung heutzutage kann man ja gar
nichts mehr sagen sondern Bullshit
einfach nur weil wir Menschen mit
einbeziehen und Gefühle von Menschen mit
einbeziehen was wir früher halt weniger
gemacht haben das stört halt viele Leute
weil sie es nicht gewohnt sind dass sie
einfach sagen
können was sie wollen und dass ich Leute
darüber verletzt fühlen können das haben
sich auch früher schon Leute verletzt
gefühlt aber man hat einfach nicht auf
sie gehört deswegen versuche ich immer
vorsichtig zu formulieren was ich sagen
möchte vielleicht habt ihr ja schon die
Phase die ich gerade habe durchgemacht
und könnten mir sogar Tipps geben sagen
ob es geholfen hat ob ich
umprogrammieren konntet ich glaube halt
nicht dass es eine Sache ist die ein
paar Wochen also ein paar Tagen oder so
erledigt ist ich glaube das dauert halt
ich denke auch wenn ich so einschätze
würde ich sagen ich habe mich so in den
letzten zwei Jahren umprogrammiert aufs
negativ denken auf sich hoffnungslos
fühlen und den ganzen Scheiß deswegen
gebe ich mir jetzt auf jeden Fall ein
paar mehr Wochen um daran arbeiten zu
können und wenn einem Sachen halt
auffallen dann kann man halt erst dran
arbeiten und da bin ich dann
jetzt auch ganz positiv eingestellt dass
ich das schaffen werde ich habe absolut
keine Ahnung
was das hier für Wolken sind aber ist
kein Problem wir sprühen da gleich
wieder drüber
und dann bin ich einfach ein Multimedia
artist
und wenn das alles hier einfach nur
absolut großer Stuss war dann ist das
auch in Ordnung ich habe keine Ahnung ob
es sich irgendwas gesagt habe was Sinn
gemacht hat es ist auf jeden Fall
schwieriger
zu malen und sich dabei auf Worte zu
konzentrieren ich bin eigentlich jemand
der malt und dann total daran versinkt
und irgendwie vielleicht höre ich dann
Musik aber eigentlich höre ich dann
auch nicht so wirklich was wenn ich male
sich aus wie jemand der absolut im
Trance ist
so ich bin noch mal so frech und sprühe
noch mal
drüber
riecht das nicht ja schreibt mir gerne
dazu was ihr
davon haltet ich weiß ihr seid immer
sehr nett zu mir aber ihr könnt auch
ehrlich sein wenn euch das gar nicht
gefällt
sagt gern
ich denke auf jeden Fall nicht dass es
fertig fertig ist aber bei manchen
Sachen brauche ich auch einfach da
brauche ich auch Zeit da brauche ich
Zeit für das muss das muss erstmal jetzt
wirken das Bild und jetzt schreibt ihr
fleißig eure Gedanken dazu in die
Kommentare und ich habe mich sehr
gefreut mit euch diese Zeit hier
verbracht zu haben ich hoffe ihr habt
irgendwas Brot produktives machen können
denn darum geht's im Leben produktiv
sein bloß nicht faulenzen
bis zum nächsten Mal